bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
de mickaël zeze bonjour mutuelle nous
ont passé ensemble en revue l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
semaine encore marquée par l'équation
budgétaire difficile pour le
gouvernement il manque 6 milliards
d'euros dans les caisses pour 2014
reconnaît le ministre jérôme cahuzac
l'ump sort de son chapeau le chiffre de
35 milliards
et pendant ce temps le chômage continue
d'augmenter près de trois millions cent
soixante dix mille chômeurs en janvier
une loi d'aministie sociale votée au
sénat elle efface les sanctions
prononcées pour des faits commis lors de
mouvements sociaux ou syndicaux cette
proposition de loi communiste a été voté
de justesse à l'extérieur du sénat c'est
jean luc mélenchon qui assurait le show
enfin il ya eu cette semaine un
séminaire intergouvernemental sur le
numérique dix ministres pour 18 mesures
dont la protection des données
personnelles mais pas ou peu denses de
financement un plan sur le haut débit
coûterait au moins 15 milliards d'euros
ce n'est pas gagné
notre invité fleur pellerin bonjour jean
ministre chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises de l'innovation mais aussi
du numérique on va donc beaucoup en
parler dans cette émission on a une
certaine habitude celle de soumettre
notre invité un petit exercice celui du
portrait alors d'habitude on demande à
vos petits camarades de savoir un petit
peu ce qu'ils pensent de vous paie
aujourd'hui comme vous êtes
la ministre un petit peu du web eh bien
on va demander à une spécialiste
d'internet
aurélie marcireau de dresser en quelque
sorte votre portrait numérique
exactement donc j'ai étudié votre compte
twitter et votre page facebook
alors pour facebook un 7244 j'aime
d'ailleurs je voulais vous signaler à
propos d'amour que votre dernier message
reçu et celui d'un amoureux transi
visible ans qui aimerait que vous lui
répondit mettrait de trêve de
plaisanterie revenons à cette page
officielle a été ouverte en 2011 donc au
début de la campagne de françois
hollande avant ne trouve qu'une seule
date c'est celle de votre naissance donc
j'en ai conclu par un petit raccourci
que votre deuxième naissance politique
celle-là était donc très liée au
président de la république alors votre
photo de couverture et celle là
malavoi les trentenaires du gouvernement
le 17 mai dans les jardins l'elysée avec
cécile duflot aurélie filippetti
delphine batho et najat vallaud belkacem
sylvia pinel et pascal canfin cherchez
l'intrus
on se souvient on se souvient n'a eu
bien bonne c'est très très content on se
souvient de la une des inrocks
d'ailleurs ou girl power
vous étiez déjà en compagnie de delphine
batho aurélie filippetti visiblement
vous aimez bien ce côté bande de filles
alors l'autre photo 1 de facebook que
j'ai retenu c'est celle qu'on vient de
voir avec pierre moscovici
donc on sent on voit votre regard un
petit peu tétanisé en si vous êtes
proche de pierre moscovici qu'est ce qui
vous a donné un conseil rapidement sur
ce premier conseil des ministres
justement non je crois que on avait
beaucoup discuté avant de la perspective
effectivement la constitution d'un
gouvernement mais pas de conseils
particuliers pour ce premier conseil des
ministres que j'avais une manière
spontanée
c'était très émouvant et très
impressionnant alors revenons au
numérique y est donc à votre compte
twitter cette fois vous avez 54 mille
abonnés soit oui mais quand même
beaucoup moins que benoît hamon qui en
compte 100 49 films et il gazouille
depuis bien plus longtemps que vous
c'est un des premiers à avoir utilisé
twitter 1900 je pense encore avant mais
bon écoutez c'est toujours mieux que
delphine batho conte à 21000 un pur
priori au l'on note une évolution de vos
tweets depuis vous êtes ministre ils
sont un peu plus standard ya un peu
moins de ifeelgoods comme au soir 10 cm
et un peu plus de gens la regardent et
visite de la passionnante experts
futurotextiles d'acheter des cinq sens
et l'histoire
j'imagine même que ce n'est peut-être
pas vous qui l'avait rédigée en revanche
en othe vos talents de photographe avec
par exemple celui là c'était lors d'un
déplacement à marseille
jolie photo mh quel tableau qu'il avait
prise ouais ouais alors le carton absolu
sur twitter quand même vous l'avez
réalisée grâce à cet homme syl le
chanteur comme rien de gagner en style
vous l'avez rencontré la tweet et
combien il était heureux de rencontrer
une compatriote
car vous êtes né en corée en le servant
d'être d'être adopté adoptez savez vous
combien de personnes suivent le fameux
tsai sur twitter ouais de l'union en
2010 elle a renforcé ma notoriété je
vais dépasser benoît
bon je pensais de commencer s'est bien
passé cette rencontre oui c'était bref
mais sympathique donc pour la prochaine
fois si vous voulez encore augmenter
votre potentiel twitter je vous
conseille d'un fauteuil barack obama
parce que je sais il a capté falloir que
ça rapporte combien beaucoup aussi
beaucoup sur la page facebook et sur la
non c'est sûrement beaucoup plus que
tout homme politique trassari allemands
savent certainement aurélie merci
beaucoup pour ce portrait numérique et
nous on va poursuivre la semaine
commence évidemment au lundi c'est
normal vincent peillon a une nouvelle
idée
vincent peillon ministre de l'éducation
nationale a déjà suscité l'émoi en
imposant la semaine de quatre jours et
demi en primaire et voilà qu'il récidive
en proposant des vacances d'été
raccourcies à six semaines
improvisation cri l'opposition mais en
ce lundi le ministre persiste et signe
cécile freixinos c'est peut-être
l'annnonce de trop déjà empêtrés dans la
réforme de la semaine des quatre jours
dans le primaire
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
vincent peillon propose un nouveau
chantier pour l'école raccourcir les
vacances scolaires d'été à six semaines
au lieu de deux mois actuellement
et les organiser selon deux zones
géographiques
le calendrier a beau être fixés pour
les enseignants dénoncent une nouvelle
fois un manque de concertation là qui
sont du zonage va poser des problèmes
pas que personne de l'éducation aux
parents ou je ne sais pas si les
familles ont toutes le choix de prendre
leurs vacances au moment où leurs
enfants seront dans la zone en vacances
donc traitons déjà les questions
regardons où il ya des points à lever et
ensuite on verra ce qu'il est possible
de faire l'opposition aussi s'est
emparée du dossier
elle crie à l'improvisation systématique
et demande un recadrage du ministre de
l'éducation nationale on n'y comprend
pas grand chose monsieur p -o a quand
même le chic pour mettre un désordre
sans pareil dans l'éducation nationale
en visite dans une école de 500 ni
vincent peillon s'est défendu face aux
accusations d' annonces intempestives
il plaide la concertation j'ai entendu
quelqu'un
françois fillon je lui ai entendu dire
précipitation j'annonce une discussion
pour 2015
je les ai entendus dire absence de
concertation c'est bien une discussion
que j'annonce enseignants parents
d'élèves professionnels du tourisme les
intérêts divergent sur la question de la
durée des vacances et du tonnage avant
de s'y attaquer en 2015
le ministre de l'éducation nationale a
d'abord une autre réforme de taille
celle des rythmes scolaires hebdomadaire
à l'école au collège puis au lycée alors
vincent peillon qui a été mardi la cible
des questions au gouvernement pendant la
séance
on en a sept ces annonces intempestives
par voie de presse disent les syndicats
est-ce qu'il a la bonne méthode votre
vincent peillon
je crois qu'il a la bonne méthode dans
la mesure où comme il le dit dans le
sujet que vous avez présenté il est dans
une phase de concertation donc ils
ouvrent une discussion il n'est pas en
train d'imposer de manière autoritaire
des décisions qu'il aurait prise dans le
secret de son cabinet il ouvre des
discussions il les met sur la table et
il propose à toutes les parties
prenantes dans d'en délibérer donc je
crois qu'il est dans une simple en deux
lots balle plutôt que des annonces comme
ça il faut bien annoncer un moment le
sujet de la discussion et c'est ce qu'il
fait donc il ouvre une concertation sur
un sujet qu'il met sur la table si on
rassemble les rythmes scolaires les
vacances la semaine de quatre jours ça
commence à faire beaucoup
ça fait peut être beaucoup d'annoncés
possiblité peut-être une question que
vous pose tout simplement on est dans
une
on est dans une réforme des rythmes
scolaires la durée des vacances l'adulte
la durée de la journée scolaire
l'étalement des heures de cours sur la
semaine tout ça fait partie d'une même
réflexion sur la manière dont on
enseigne aux enfants
et de quelle manière on s'adapte au
rythme des enfants donc je pense que
c'est bien de poser des questions au
même moment et d'avoir cette discussion
d'ensemble sur la durée de la journée
idéale parce qu'ils activent difficile
la gauche la droite aux effets y est à
chaque fois ça s'est passé dans la rue
et des concertations ou eu lieu mais
toujours avec un échec mais c'est pour
ça qu'il faut privilégier le dialogue et
je pense que c'est ce que le ministre de
l'éducation fait mais c'est vrai que
c'est difficile parce que comme le dit
très bien le journaliste dans le
reportage il ya plusieurs intérêts qui
s'affrontent parfois les parents ne
pense pas la même chose que les
enseignants qui ne pense pas la même
chose que les professionnels du tourisme
et donc c'est important d'ouvrir cette
discussion est ce que le fait
un vrai dire un petit peu indiscipliné
on se rappelle qu'il avait notamment
parlé de lui-même d'un débat sur la
dépénalisation du cannabis il s'était
exprimé très tôt sur la semaine de
quatre jours et demi
vous pensez qu'il faut de la discipline
quand on est ministre vous qui
inaugurait de votre carrière
ministérielle il faut pas parler avant
le premier ministre il faut lui en
parler avant ou bien comme ça on peut se
permettre on peut s'autoriser des
initiatives personnelles
écoutez moi je trouve il ya un principe
qui est la solidarité gouvernementale
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où il
ya une décision qui est entérinée par le
président la république ou par le
premier ministre le gouvernement et
solidaires pour défendre cette cette
décision maintenant un gouvernement ce
n'est pas un troupeau avec des gens qui
n'ont pas d'opinion et qui ne peuvent
pas exprimer un point de vue donc je
pense que c'est aussi très bien qu'il ya
une diversité de points de vue qui
s'exprime
l'important étant qu'une fois que la
décision est prise et bien tout le monde
soit aligné sur cette position c'est
vrai fleur pellerin en langues et en ce
moment que tout remonte à l'elysée que
c'est françois hollande et ses équipes
qui décide de tout et qu'on passe
quasiment plus par matignon non c'est
pas vrai du tout non c'est pas vrai du
tout je pense que le prince le
fonctionnement des institutions est
revenue à la normale j'allais dire
compte tenu de la tradition de la vème
république c'est à dire qu'il ya un
travail interministériel et lorsque
nécessaire il ya un arbitrage qui est
fait par matignon
c'est comme ça que ça se passe après il
ya des anneaux qui sont portées par le
président de la république comme c'était
le cas sur le très haut débit par
exemple parce que c'était un engagement
du candidat françois hollande devenu
président de la république mais les
décisions se prennent bien entendu à
matignon photo fonctionnement normal de
la république à leur passé au mardi
recherche milliards désespérément
effectivement avec une croissance en
berne il manquera quelques milliards
dans les caisses de l'état en 2014 6
milliards du gouvernement
au moins 35 calcul l'ump alors on ce
mardi la bataille des chiffres se joue à
l'ump
elisa berthelot mais qui veut gagner des
milliards
ce n'est pas un jeu mais la nouvelle
priorité du gouvernement
car pour 2014 il manque déjà 6 milliards
d'euros si les économistes doivent
beaucoup
elles ne peuvent à elles seules
permettre l'ajustement budgétaire
il y voit aussi des recettes en 2013
nous allons un niveau de recettes dont
témoigne le taux de prélèvements
obligatoires
il faudra que c'est pas les manches de
l'histoire restent les mêmes sans
augmenter je l'espère en 2014
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faudra
compenser des recettes constatées en
2013 et dont nous savons que nous
pouvons aller constater en 2004 mais
déjà la bataille des chiffres commencent
l'opposition a fait les comptes ce n'est
pas six milliards qu'ils manquent mais
beaucoup plus le gouvernement qui nous
la joue sur l'air de tout va très bien
madame la marquise
avec un déficit ou monsieur cahuzac nous
annonce qui a 6 milliards à trouver en
fait nous quand on fait les additions
c'est pas six mais on est plutôt sur une
fourchette de 35 à 40 parce qu'il n'a
juste rien à voir 35 à 40 milliards en
plus pour financer le crédit d'impôt les
emplois d'avenir ou encore pour combler
le déficit des économies en perspective
ou bien recourir de nouveau au
prélèvement via les niches fiscales s'il
ya un effort à faire
il faut que ce soit dans la justice
fiscale nous avons commencé l'année
dernière à peynier l'ensemble des niches
fiscales pour voir celles qui ne
correspondent pas aux priorités curité
fixé l'emploi en priorité le
développement des entreprises et les
préoccupations énergétiques
une réforme qui n'aura de toute façon
pas lieu avant plusieurs mois pour le
rapporteur général du budget aucune loi
de finances rectificative n'est prévue
avant l'été leur fleur pellerin vous
elle était membre de la cour des comptes
les finances publiques vous connaissez
est ce qu'on va pouvoir échapper à une
hausse d'impôt réellement alors je crois
que s'agissant de 2014
les prévisions ni les prévisions de
croissance ni les prévisions de recettes
ne sont pour l'instant arrêté donc je
pense qu'il faut se garder d' anticiper
et se concentrer pour la somme de 6
milliards qui manquerait les prévisions
ne sont pas encore connues donc nous
attendons de les avoir avant de savoir
de quelle manière nous ajusterons les le
budget pour pouvoir être responsable et
conforme à la trajectoire budgétaire qui
a fixé le président de la république qui
est ainsi que le premier ministre donc
je pense qu'il faut attendre d'avoir ses
prévisions avant de d'anticiper sur ce
qui va se produire en 2014 sur 2013 je
crois que ce que le gouvernement a
démontré ce à la fois cette gestion
responsable tout en privilégiant un
certain nombre de d'investissements
d'avenir on parlera je crois tout à
l'heure du très haut débit et donc il ya
des choix qui ont été faits en matière
d'investissements d'avenir et qui montre
bien que nous essayons de concilier la
rigueur la responsabilité budgétaire
avec le maintien de perspectives de
croissance pour notre école d'économie
un petit peu partout alors absolument
mais je trouve que la laddh la droite a
beau jeu de dire il manque tant il faut
faire des économies
lorsqu'on regarde l'évolution des
dépenses et core 1,6 milliard contre 35
on est déjà de quelques schémas qu'on se
mette d'accord sur le bilan et je suis
désolé de dire revenir mais quand on
regarde l'évolution des dépenses
publiques sous la gestion de la droite
on voit qu'elle explose le déficit
budgétaire si nous avions laissé filer
les dépenses et et si nous n'avions pas
toucher aux prélèvements obligatoires le
déficit budgétaire cette année on a été
supérieur à 6% du produit intérieur brut
donc je crois que la droite devrait déjà
se concentrer et faire son amende
honorable sur la sur sa propre gestion
avant de donner des leçons de bonne
gestion à ce gouvernement
les entreprises
quand jérôme cahuzac pierre moscovici
annoncent des hausses d'impôts pour les
entreprises vous qui vous occupez des
pme les fragilisent ces entreprises on
et fragilise pas parce que tout le
travail du gouvernement précisément mon
travail entre le projet de loi de
finances rectificative de l'année
dernière et les projets de loi de
finances successifs de cette année ont
consisté à justement répartir justement
équitablement équitablement la charge
fiscale supplémentaire l'effort fiscal
supplémentaire demandé à nos entreprises
et donc en particulier la loi de
finances rectificative la première que
nous ayons fait voter consistait à
réduire l'écart entre la taxation
effective des grands groupes et la
taxation des pme parce que les pme n'ont
pas les moyens d'optimiser fiscalement
et donc ce que nous avons fait c'est que
nous avons réduit tous les mécanismes
qui permettait aux grandes entreprises
de payer moins d'impôt sur les sociétés
que les pme
en revanche les pme ont été largement
préservés par le nouvel effort que nous
avons demandé aux entreprises donc les
pme n'ont pas été fragilisées au
contraire nous avons mis en oeuvre des
dispositions et des dispositifs pour
l'épreuve préserver pour les protéger
une coupe de la tva la tva faut qu'il
faut l'augmenter ou pas les députés ps
sont pour la tva sur le taux normal le
taux il ya le taux normal est évidemment
et puis allez tous vous avez qu il a
déjà été décidé à partir de 2014 de
l'alimenter la série cette semaine
demande encore une hausse du taux le
plus important et une baisse du taux
intermédiaire de 10 à 9 % sur certains
points on voit bien quand même qu'on
cherche au corps du côté de la tva nous
ce que nous souhaitons et ce qui a été
définie comme comme ligne directrice par
le président de la république c'est
d'avoir une réforme fiscale qui soit
équitable et donc nous souhaitons
protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
personnes qui sont les plus fragiles
aujourd'hui la tva c'est quelque chose
qui est relativement aveugle nous avons
déjà prévu pour financer le crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi d hausse
différenciée de tva en essayant de
protéger les produits des produits de
première nécessité je crois que
maintenant le président la république
l'a dit si un effort supplémentaire à
faire pour respecter notre trajectoire
budgétaire sera plutôt du côté de la
haie dépenses et asocial ce serait pas
une piste quand même ça a été
complètement abandonné à la mesure de
nicolas
il avait regretté par un petit peu parce
que finalement c'était une façon de
mesurer à réduire les charges des
entreprises
oui peut-être mais de manière à juste en
faisant porter l'effort sur ne
contribuent des contribuables les plus
défavorisés où les plus pauvres et ça je
crois que c'est un choix très clair du
gouvernement de refuser ce type de ce
type de mesures
alors pour l'opposition évidemment cette
semaine ça a été l'occasion de fustiger
la politique économique du gouvernement
écoutez cet échange lors des questions
d'actualité entre henri guaino et le
premier ministre
quand je vous regarde agir quand je
regarde votre gouvernement et votre
majorité je ne peux m'empêcher de penser
aux hommes de la quatrième république
qui passaient leur temps à marchander
avec tout le monde
jusqu'à ce que la faillite économique et
politique amène le pays au bord du
gouffre quand ça serait vous dont
monsieur le premier ministre d'être un
président du conseil la quatrième
république pour devenir enfin un vrai
premier ministre de la vème république
j'attends avec impatience le rendez-vous
de la motion de censure que chaque
semaine l'ump annonce parce que moi
monsieur guaino je n'ai pas de leçon à
recevoir de votre grandiloquence moi
j'aime la france
et j'aime autant la france que vous et
j'ai confiance dans la capacité des
françaises et des français pour que
notre pays redevienne ce grand pays et
françois fillon est allé plus loin cette
semaine parce qu'il a dit 2013 c'est une
année perdue pour la france à cause de
la politique pas de cap pas d'envergure
de vous naviguez à vue selon lui mais je
crois que 2007 2012 on était cinq années
perdues pour la france on peut dire ça
aussi nous avons hérité d'une situation
en matière de finances publiques qui est
dramatique et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous devons faire beaucoup
d'économies de dépenses du côté de
l'état chose que la droite n'a jamais
fait et par ailleurs c'est vrai que nous
avons dû augmenter la pression fiscale
sur en faisant l'effort de 2
dax et 7,7 de recettes sur les
conséquences favorisant une politique de
rigueur d'austérité
elle porte un nom c'est une politique de
responsabilité et je crois que ce qui
est très important c'est de bien dire
qu'il y a deux volets dans notre action
politique notre politique économique il
ya cette responsabilité budgétaire qui
est absolument indispensable pour avoir
la confiance des marchés mais aussi pour
respecter nos engagements auprès de
partenaires européens et parallèlement
il y à un certain nombre de nos
engagements qui ont été pris pour des
investissements d'avenir et pour aider
les entreprises à renouer avec la
croissance avec l'emploi avec
l'investissement le créer le pacte de
compétitivité c'est une mesure qui est
favorable aux entreprises pour qu'elles
créent de l'emploi et qu'elles
investissent tout ce que nous faisons en
matière d'investissements d'avenir c'est
aussi quelque chose qui va dans ce sens
là donc il est important d'avoir ces
deux ces deux branches de notre action
en tête
guaino en parlant de président du
conseil c'est qu'il ressent comme un
certain flottement sur les chiffres du
chômage par exemple on a dit au début de
semaine qu'on n'arriverait pas inverser
cette année la courbe du chômage
françois hollande en conseil des
ministres mercredi vous y étiez sans
doute dit on pourrait peut-être y
arriver est ce qu'il faudrait pas quand
même être plus plus plus précis plus
concret sur dans les dents les
affirmations qui sont faites parce que
la déception c'est un engagement c'est
pas une affirmation quand même c'est un
engagement c'est c'est une expression
d'une volonté après on ne peut
évidemment pas prévoir nous ne sommes
pas de gens dont on ne pouvait pas
prévoir à la fois ce que sera la
croissance cette année et vous savez
bien que le taux de chômage dépend aussi
de la croissance
donc il ya une affirmation du volant
cette indécision de la croissance non je
suis pas d'accord c'est il ya
l'expression d'une volonté vous allez on
en est à plus de 20 mois de hausse du
chômage consécutifs donc
donc c'est pas la hausse du chômage
avait commencé bien avant que ce
gouvernement ne prenne ses fonctions
donc je crois que nous nous mettons en
oeuvre un certain nombre de dispositifs
que soient les les emplois les contrats
de génération ou d'avenir le crédit
impôt compétitivité emploi le pacte de
compétitivité qui contient des mesures
également sur la compétitivité hors
coûts des entreprises d'apporter la paix
il ya beaucoup de mesures qui visent
justement à atteindre cet objectif que
nous affirmons avec force parce que il
faut avoir une volonté politique et s'y
tenir je pense que c'est très important
et c'est au mercredi
mercredi cette amnistie c'était un
rendez vous très attendu pour la gauche
sénatoriale allait-elle se retrouver
pour un vote sur la loi d' amnistie pour
les syndicalistes et les militants
associatifs poursuivis et condamnés pour
certaines actions la réponse est oui
mais le vote est passé de très peu avec
une pression celle d'un homme jean luc
mélenchon gerbe rabier mettre la
pression à quelques minutes de la séance
au sénat
parmi les manifestants quelques
militants potentiellement concernés par
cette future loi d'aministie j'ai été
condamné deux fois par l'état parce que
j'ai arrêté d'être un pour maintenir des
lignes ferroviaires et des gaves en zone
rurale on doit être amnistié parce qu'on
s'est battu pour la république pour la
défense du service public et d
inadmissible qu'on soit condamné porteur
du projet de loi les sénateurs
communistes sont venus apporter leur
soutien
avant de rejoindre l'hémicycle ce sont
des personnes qui s'engagent pour
défendre une cause donc c'est une
revendication collective et au prix d'un
d'une masse de gens qui contestent un
roux devront être condamné l'attraction
de ce rassemblement c'est l'ancien
candidat du front de gauche à la
présidentielle
après avoir dit que ceux qui ne voteront
pas le texte ne sont pas de gauche jean
luc mélenchon est venu s'assurer que les
réticences de certains socialistes ne
bloqueront pas le texte
c'est des résistances qui viennent de
hausse et jean marc ayrault valls
hollande qui ont freiné des quatre fers
pour que pourquoi selon vous
ben parce que leur ligne c2 le maintien
de l'ordre social et le lait cajoleries
au cac 40 va me la démangeait de
walbourg être dans l'hémicycle lui qui a
siégé dans l'hémicycle du sénat pendant
20 ans a dû sage en suivre les débats
depuis la tribune des visiteurs très
vite rassuré par christiane taubira qui
assurer la neutralité du gouvernement
sur ce texte
le gouvernement a donc écouté avec la
plus grande attention et sera très
probablement amené à s'en remettre à la
sagesse de votre assemblée et je crois
que nous faisons oeuvre utile et surtout
que nous faisons là oeuvre de justice
merci applaudi par les banques
communiste la ministre s'est abstenu de
trop modifier le texte les sénateurs
socialistes en sont néanmoins chargé en
limitant l'amnistié à une petite partie
des délits reprochés
pas sûr que le texte final contente
totalement les porteurs du projet
rappelle textes votés adopté mais amendé
par exemple on exclut les violences
physiques contre les personnes on a
l'impression que le gouvernement vote
accepte mais alors du bout des doigts
est ce que je me trompe
non je crois que la recherche était
celle d'un équilibre entre la protection
à des droits fondamentaux des salariés
et puis en même temps la production
d'une centaine de l'égalité vous parler
de violences physiques ou d'agressions
physiques je crois qu'il ya quand même
une limite à ce qu'on peut accepter
d'amnistié et je crois que c'est ces
orientations des biens bon voilà c'est
fait
s'appelle ou quatre sages l'appel au
cassage dit laurence parisot justement
ne peut pas laisser les syndicalistes ou
faire je pense que là l'expression de la
sagesse du gouvernement ça a été
justement la recherche d'un équilibre
comme je le disais tout à l'heure entre
permettre l'expression des droits
syndicaux en grève ou le par la
dégradation des biens et en même temps
posé les limites justement poser des
limites à ce qu'il est possible
d'excusés dame initiée dans le cadre de
l'exercice de ses droits et je crois que
c'est ça que le gouvernement l'un d'eux
dans cette position à ce que disent ils
n'auront pas raison je vous soumets
juste cette petite phrase est un appel
au cassage qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
laurence parisot est dans son rôle je
pense que je pense que c'est précisément
pour répondre à ce type d'affirmation
que le gouvernement défende une position
équilibrée il s'en est remis à la
sagesse de
de l'assemblée d'accord et jean luc
mélenchon quand il dit ceux qui ne
voteront pas ce texte n'est pas peur de
la rue de votre côté non je crois que il
ya eu la volonté maintes fois exprimée
par ce gouvernement d'avoir une approche
sur la plupart des problèmes et nous
avons les problèmes le dialogue social
d'avoir une concertation avec d'une part
les entreprises et leurs représentants
des entreprises et d'autre part les
parts des organisations syndicales et
tout ce que nous avons fait jusqu'à
présent sur le l'accord national
interprofessionnel sur un certain nombre
de grands sujets qui sont structurants
économique ou sociétaux nous avons
souhaité associer toutes les parties et
je crois que cette méthode de
concertation
et bien c'est un peu ce qui fait la
différence de ce gouvernement par
rapport au précédent encore passer à
l'assemblée donc on n'est pas tout à
fait sûr que les députés socialistes
suivent on a un peu l'impression d'un
cadeau sénateurs communistes qui sont
parfois assez peu disciplinés dans la
majorité comme tu peux appel du pied
pour calmer comme pas de cadeau c'était
à sa geste sagesse c'est sur la question
d'un bistrot je crois vraiment que cette
discussion est la position du
gouvernement a correspondu en une fois à
la volonté d'affirmer les valeurs de la
gauche qui sont celles du progrès social
et la défense des intérêts des salariés
et en même temps la volonté de limiter
un petit peu la santé chacun dans son
rôle et c'est ce qu'on retiendra pour ce
sont des papiers
ce mercredi encore on repart le cumul
des mandats une quarantaine de députés
socialistes signe dans le quotidien le
monde une tribune demandant
l'application de la loi des les
municipales de 2014 il rappelle que
c'était un engagement majeur du candidat
hollande on va vous montrer un petit
échantillon de commentaires dans la
majorité recueillie aux quatre colonnes
par aurélien romano les français
comprennent pas qu'on tergiverse
ensuite il faut la faire voter si pour
la voter il faut que ce soit 2017
cessera en 2017 si vous que ce soit en
2014 ce sera en 2014 avec la date et
secondaires mais la réforme doit être
votée maintenant ils ont raison on doit
prendre cette décision une fois pour
toutes on va pas passer des mois et des
mois à parler du non cumul du cumul
voilà soit on est pour le non cumul on
adopte un tête si on l'appliquent
soit on considère qu'il ya encore le
temps de débattre et on remet ça la
prochaine législature
voilà je considère que le non cumul des
mandats est nécessaire mais avant moi je
propose que l'on prenne des mesures tout
de suite c'est à dire qu'on interdise le
cumul des indemnités tout de suite
suffit de le voter dans la prochaine loi
de finances l'indemnité qui sont déjà
plafonnés info quand même faut quand
même le rappeler fleur pellerin faut-il
ou non appliquer le non cumul dès 2014
où c'est que le ps est pour et le
gouvernement plutôt pas pour ben je
crois qu'il ya aussi un sujet juridique
ainsi va la raison pour laquelle il ya
un avis du conseil d'état qui a été
sollicité pour savoir si on peut d'un
point de vue du droit et la constitution
appliquées de manière rétroactive à des
mandats qui sont déjà engagés
cette règle maintenant il est vrai comme
l'a rappelé carrément dont fort
justement c'était un engagement fort du
président de la république et je pense
que les débats
il faut que c'est du temps où il faut
l'appliquer la vôtre votre position à
vous c'est ma position à moi c'est qu'il
faut pour une fois l'appliquer je pense
qu'on en a beaucoup discuté et il faut
la paix si c'est peu si c'est
juridiquement possible l'appliquer au
plus vite mais je encore une fois et il
faut s'assurer que cette application
rétroactive et bien ne sera pas
contestée il ne sera pas contestable
donc désaccord un petit peu au
gouvernement quand on entend manuel
valls qui dit c'est pas une priorité que
ça pourrait provoquer dès midi des
solutions parce qu'évidemment il y aura
des législatives partielles à
l'assemblée nationale quand même allégé
des accords dans votre propre là je
pense que c'est pas un désaccord de fond
je pense que tout le monde est d'accord
pour appliquer cette mesure qui était un
engagement encore une fois du président
de la république et qui est aussi un
élément de modernisation la démocratie
et de diversification aussi de je pense
du
personnel politique donc je pense que
sur le fond et sur la philosophie même
du principe tout le monde est d'accord
après les conséquences que cela peut
avoir la question de la
constitutionnalité et c'est tout cela
faire un peu débat c'est une question
qui est plus je dirais logistiques et
organisationnels il ya eu un petit
groupe qui a été fait dans le groupe ps
au sénat par des journalistes près de
50% des sénateurs ne voteraient pas le
texte
aujourd'hui ça vous inspire quelque
chose ou pas voilà il ya aussi un sujet
de savoir s'il est possible alors l'état
de faire de faire voter la loi
et puisque c'est un engagement fort et
que c'est quelque chose auquel nous
sommes attachés c'est vrai qu'il faut
s'assurer que cette loi pourra être
votées dont ils regorgent de ne pas y
avoir de majorité pour voter cette loi
vous vos chiffres vos chiffres montrent
que c'est quelque chose qui ne peut pas
être complètement exclu donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya dans ces cas là semblait aussi
il peut y avoir un membre de majorité
sur je pense que c'est pour ça que c'est
important de pouvoir même si nous sommes
tous d'accord sur le principe pouvoir
bien convaincre une majorité de
parlementaires pour faire en sorte que
ce texte puisse être votée attendez vous
dire il va falloir encore du temps pour
débattre entre eux où on imagine alors
nous sommes jeudi et le gouvernement se
penche sur votre dossier celui du
numérique
et oui une dizaine de ministres dont
vous évidemment était ce jeudi avec le
premier ministre à gennevilliers pour un
séminaire gouvernemental sur le
numérique à la sortie 18 mesures
annoncés touchant entre autres à la
formation à la protection des données
personnelles
résumé de jean baptiste de glace tout un
symbole pour parler numérique le
gouvernement a déserté paris direction
l'université de gennevilliers une ville
de banlieue en pleine mutation numérique
partout et doit être aussi pour tous
pour une fois les ministres ne pourront
pas être accusé de tweets et en réunion
les caisses sont vides mais le
gouvernement doit imaginer des solutions
pour développer le numérique
accompagnement de start-up formation
professionnelle création d'emplois
d'avenir en particulier dans les
services à la personne
autant de pistes explorées par le
premier ministre notre politique pour le
numérique va bien sûr bien au delà des
infrastructures
mon ambition est de fortifier le tissu
des entreprises françaises de ce secteur
de favoriser l'émergence de leaders
mondiaux mais aussi de faire en sorte
que tous les autres acteurs de
l'économie s'approprie le numérique
depuis les artisans jusqu'aux grands
groupes industriels
en tout 150 millions d'euros seront
débloqués pour soutenir l'investissement
des entreprises
pour le gouvernement le numérique c'est
aussi la protection des données
personnelles
jean marc ayrault annonce une loi sur le
sujet pour 2014
les caisses sont vides un disait jean
baptiste dérouler sans marié revenir là
dessus parce que c'est quand même un
vrai problème sur le fond une loi en
2014 donc sur la protection des données
personnelles vous pouvez plus précis sur
les moyens de renforcer sa protection
là il ya effectivement trois aspects il
ya un aspect sûr je dirai tout à l'heure
mais sur dans ce séminaire il y avait un
aspect sur la jeunesse un aspect sur la
compétitivité des entreprises pour qui
le décale le numérique est un élément
très important est effectivement un
aspect droits et libertés sur internet
parce que ça d'abord il y avait un
engagement de campagne aussi dans ce
domaine du président la république sur
la création d'une zone de corpus
juridique s'appliquant à internet parce
qu'aujourd'hui notre législation est
notre réglementation
elles ne sont pas tout à fait adapté à
protéger nos fichiers personnels par
exemple voilà donc
un enjeu très fort de souveraineté parce
que nous nous rendons compte aujourd'hui
que d'un point de vue économique nous
laissons une trace numérique sur un
certain nombre de sites que des
opérateurs économiques exploitent sans
que jamais nous n'en ayons la
rétribution et qui n'est pas taxée en
france donc ça c'est un vrai sujet de
souveraineté économique et par ailleurs
il ya un vrai une sorte de défiance de
la plupart de nos concitoyens à l'égard
de la manière dont sont traités leurs
données personnelles sur ses sites de
tous les sondages le montrent et donc
tous souhaitons nous renforcer la
maîtrise qu'à chacun de l'utilisation
qui est faite de ses données
personnelles sur ses sites en renforçant
la protection pour être à renforcer ce
qu'on a les moyens
concrètement de le faire bien sûr on a
on pourrait évidemment renforcer le rôle
de la cnil et on va bien d'ailleurs que
la cnil en ce moment est très active sur
sur ces sujets là ça ne vous aura pas
échappé
et puis par ailleurs aussi travailler
avec ces plateformes on n'est pas non
plus dans un combat sont des acteurs
avec lesquels on peut discuter pour
justement permettre aux personnes de
mieux gérer leurs paramètres de
confidentialité ou la façon dont sont
utilisés leurs données personnelles sur
les sites pour faire par exemple de la
publicité ciblée ou pas donc ça c'est
quelque chose sur lequel nous souhaitons
travailler et légiférer
vous admettez aussi qu'on a un certain
retard pour la cyberdéfense on a
beaucoup entendu parler de ce mot
hacking évidemment sur tous les sites
que l'on utilise
on va parler de facebook de twitter etc
vous admettez que la france est quand
même un petit peu en retard et qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour améliorer un
petit peu tout ça je pense pas que la
france soit particulièrement en retard
vous voyez qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
pays occidentaux de même les etats-unis
qui ont été la cible de cyber attaques
à bangkok c'est vrai c'est un vrai c'est
un vrai enjeu et je pense que le
ministère de la défense et le ministère
de l'intérieur
on travaillait à développer des outils
nous avons eu d'ailleurs lors du
séminaire une présentation qui a été
faite par les services concernés par par
la cyber défense ou la cybersécurité
nous expliquer de quelle manière ils
protégeaient les informations ou les
sites sensibles de l'état et des
entreprises privées d'ailleurs c'est
très important aussi il ya des
entreprises privées qui sont la cible de
ces cyber-attaques donc nous structurons
une réponse évidemment ce sont des
choses qui sont pour certaines un peu
confidentiel mais nous sommes nous
sommes
tout à fait dans le dans la marche du
temps en la matière et nous avons des
acteurs d'ailleurs français qui sont
extrêmement compétitif dans sur ces
marchés qui sont en croissance
alors on va parler un petit peu de
l'argent du numérique vous savez il ya
deux sénateurs qui ont remis un rapport
sur le haut débit et tire un petit peu
une sonnette d'alarmé 80% du territoire
ne serait pas couvert et surtout il
demande un financement va écouter l'un
des deux sénateurs il s'agit de yves
rome
il faudrait pour les collectivités
territoriales sur la durée des dix ans
mobilisé à peu près 15 milliards d'euros
il faut donc significativement que
l'état sur la même durée puisse
concourir à au minimum 50% du coût de
cet objectif en subventionnant les
collectivités territoriales et cette
hauteur alors 80% du territoire français
pas vraiment couvert par le haut débit
et il demande la visiblement des moyens
financiers pour les collectivités
locales alors que ses propres
collectivités locales et on leur demande
de faire des efforts en temps de crise
comment on va faire comment confiance à
des choses différentes on parle du très
haut débit donc l'engagement c'était
bien la couverture en très haut débit
donc avec un investissement très
important en fibre optique 1 et non pas
et non pas dans le cuivre comme c'est le
cas actuellement pour l'adsl donc nous
nous avons calculé et d'ailleurs sont
des chiffres qui sont confirmées par
l'autorité de régulation des
communications électroniques arcep que
cette année un chantier qui représentait
un investissement de l'ordre de 20 25
milliards mais d'investissement public
et privé puisqu'il ya des zones qui sont
rentables si vous déployer la fibre à
paris ou dans les grandes métropoles
vous allez vous allez perspectives de
rentabilité donc là les opérateurs
privés comme par exemple un peu mieux
leur corps est donc là vous avez des
opérateurs privés qui auront un intérêt
à investir et qui vont investir en
revanche c'est vrai qu'il ya des zones
dans lesquelles le coût de la prise pour
aller jusqu'à jusque chez les gens est
beaucoup plus élevé et là il faut qu'il
y ait du subventionnement collectivités
locales
il y aura déjà supprimé des milliards de
notation le ce sur quoi le gouvernement
s'est engagé et là encore contrairement
aux gouvernements précédents qui n'avait
pas financé cette péréquation justement
pour faire en sorte que ceux qui sont
dans des zones non rentables puisse être
soutenue financièrement et bien le
gouvernement s'est engagé à financer 50
% du coût des investissements dans les
zones non rentables
donc il y aura un investissement des
collectivités locales c'est normal mais
la demande est nommé le voilà mais le
milieu gouvernement appuiera ces
démarches à hauteur de 50% alors que
jusqu'à présent c'était plutôt de
l'ordre de 30% le taux de
subventionnement constatez donc on est
vraiment la danse dans quelque chose de
le faire payer les géants internet pour
les forcer à ça vous pouvez alors à un
autre sujet on ne compte pas là-dessus
évidemment on n'intègre pas dans le plan
de financement moi je me suis appuyé sur
des financements certains pour financer
mon bilan est donc le plan aujourd'hui
de déploiement du très haut débit que
j'ai présenté au premier ministre qui a
été validé par le premier ministre et le
président de la république s'appuie sur
des financements qui sont certains à
savoir les redevances supplémentaires
qui vont être payés par les opérateurs
de téléphonie mobile pour utiliser une
bande de fréquences pour déployer de la
4g donc du très haut débit mobile c'est
ce quelque chose qui est qu'elles
encourent et ces ressources là qui
s'ajouteront aux crédits au reliquat du
programme d'investissements d'avenir qui
qui existe déjà
permettent de financer l'investissement
de l'état dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
donc ça sont des financements qui sont
certains et en plus le gouvernement
s'est il avait déjà obtenu que j'ai déjà
obtenu qui ont été validées qui ont été
annoncées par le président la république
et par ailleurs puisque ce sont des
investissements de long terme dont
certains seront quand même rentable mais
pour lesquels les collectivités ont
besoin d'être aidés par sous la forme de
prêts nous allons mettre en place et
mobilisé environ 20 milliards d'euros
des fonds d'épargné qui sont gérés par
la caisse des dépôts le pur sur
l'excellent du livret a mais non enfin
le surplus du livre a pour faire des
prêts à très long terme et à taux
attractifs ce qui n'existait pas jusqu'à
présent de ça semble bien parce que les
sites et locales de tous âges raphaël
clément
la couverture absolument pas on a
installé une mission très haut débit qui
pilotera le déploiement du très haut
débit qui est là pour aider les
collectivités locales sur un plan
technique et financier à monter leur
projet et qui se transformera le
président la république l'a annoncé la
semaine dernière en établissement public
donc il ya une vraie pilotage de l'état
il ya un financement et ça montre bien
là aussi et j'ai obtenu gain de cause et
j'en suis très contente parce que c'est
un investissement pas pour moi bien sûr
mais pour nos concitoyens parce que
c'est une vraie demande
salma un investissement d'avenir c'est
un enjeu d'attractivité pour le
territoire de compétitivité pour les
entreprises
et ça montre bien que même dans cette
période de restrictions budgétaires et
bien le gouvernement fait des choix pour
des priorités qu'il considère comme
stratégique compétitivité aussi pour les
agriculteurs d'ailleurs parce qu'on voit
qu'ils utilisent et juste les centrales
seront prioritaires sont plus ou moins
habiles pour parler du salon de
l'agriculture qui a ouvert ses portes
maintenant il ya presque une semaine
selon la bonne habitude les hommes
politiques ont défilé toute la semaine
au chevet d'une profession a marqué pour
une partie par le scandale de la viande
de cheval
valérie tommaso le salon de
l'agriculture
et chaque année le terrain de
prédilection de nos élus l'occasion pour
eux de se livrer chacun à leur manière
un exercice de style bien rodée destiné
à séduire un maximum d'électeurs
ainsi françois bayrou se présente-t-il
comme le défenseur des agriculteurs
c'est très choquant parce que c'est une
agriculture tout à fait de de haut
niveau de capacité technique de capacité
de production de grande qualité et en
même temps la vente de leurs produits ne
suffit pas pour vivre en plein scandale
de la viande de cheval
les écologistes sont en terrain conquis
surtout s'ils attaquent la politique de
bruxelles la commission a décidé
d'elle-même
par exemple de réautoriser les farines
animales d'arrêter les tests sur la
vache folle ça c'est complètement
invraisemblable alors maintenant il faut
étiqueté mais le commissaire européen
monsieur borg moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'il n'y avait pas beaucoup
d'allant pour obliger un étiquetage
européen à la porte de versailles
d'autres font leur show devant les
caméras nombreuses ségolène royal vient
d'y défendre le médine
ans il n'y a aucune raison que la viande
par exemple pas 5000 kilomètres avant
d'atterrir dans nos assiettes c'est
absurde
alors qu'on a de la production de
qualité à proximité mais au salon on
parle aussi politique
jean françois copé ne se prive pas d'une
critique sur françois fillon je trouve
que les élections présidentielles de
2017 c'est une chose importante mais
avant il ya 2014
voilà pour ces personnalités politiques
il serait impensable de rater ce rendez
vous annuel
cette opération de séduction fleur
pellerin vous n'y êtes pas allé au salon
de la culture c'est un exercice qui ne
vous tente pas assis ici absolument non
je n'ai pas eu au total ces cinq temps
c'était vraiment ça interministériel
mais je j'envisage d'y aller ce week-end
avec ma fille met donc en tant que mère
de famille puisque en tant que ministre
je m'habille d'arrêt mais j'espère
d'individus au début on a dit on va
terminer cette semaine par un hommage
ont appris le décès de stéphane hessel à
l'âge de 95 ans diplomates mais aussi
ancien résistant déporté savait qu'ils
avaient connu cette forte notoriété il y
a deux ans avec ce manifeste indignez
vous vendu à 4 millions d'exemplaires
je vous propose de l'écouter c'était sur
la chaîne parlementaire à l'occasion de
la journée du livre organisé à
l'assemblée nationale il ne faut jamais
laisser filer d'espérance
il faut avoir confiance votre génération
doit avoir confiance en elle
courage et savoir que ce qui paraît très
difficile à surmonter sera surmontée à
stéphane hessel que vous avez quelques
commentaires juste six députés ont
demandé à ce que françois hollande
organise un hommage national et qu'ils
soient transférées au panthéon
sans les pour oui oui absolument je
crois que l'extrême vous avez montré
je trouve être un beau message d'espoir
je crois qu'il ya cette notion de
confiance est très importante je crois
qu'on est dans une période où on est
plutôt dans une époque de défiance et je
trouve que donner aux jeunes générations
en plus venant d'un homme qui a eu cette
vie ce parcours exceptionnel
je trouve que c'est quelque chose de
positif et on manque de messages
positifs en ce moment où un ouvrage de
référence pour la jeunesse française
je crois oui je pense que c'est
simplement qu'il faut être actif en gal
chinois aujourd'hui monde de combat et
que et je pense qu'il faut épouser des
causes un peu collective
je crois que c'est un beau message à la
fois d'espoir de devoir de pensée
collective et positive sur ce message
positif que nous allons nous quitte et
merci beaucoup fleur pellerin d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci losier
on ne se retrouve pas la semaine
prochaine mais quel nom vacances
parlementaires
on se retrouve donc bien évidemment dans
quinze jours par coeur je veux merci au
revoir mon week-end est bon